I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one
shinomi which allows its user to
manipulate gravity it was eaten by
Marine Admiral fujitora in terms of
strength the gravity fruit is absurdly
powerful it allows you to control
gravity to crush opponents pull down
literal meteors and even lift insane
amounts of objects to destroy or save
you or whoever you choose perfect 25
points if I've ever seen one and
defensively the gravity Food Packs a
weighty punch as well because you can
make yourself lighter to move faster or
make yourself heavier to tank punches
and you can even create a gravity Shield
to repel attacks 22 points also allows
you to manipulate gravity in all
directions not just up or down and
produce gravity slashes that work
perfectly with a sword 18 points for
special abilities and of course since
you can make yourself fly you have the
most OP ability for everyday life 20
points also there are basically no
downsides to having this route which
brings the total to a graft-tastic 85
points yanking down the light fruit to
take the number one spot for now